[Música]
vinimos a dejar el mundo mejor de como
lo encontramos y para hacerlo debiéramos
tener presente la premisa de gandhi que
dijo si la causa es justa los medios
para defenderla también deben ser justos
como activista lesbiana he tocado tambor
en la calle he ido a foros
manifestaciones y debates de toda índole
como lesbiana mamá y activista he
escuchado afirmaciones infames acerca
del supuesto peligro que representamos
los homosexuales para los niños y las
niñas también hay afirmaciones
insultantes y denigrantes sobre mi
orientación sexual casi nunca me han
agredido físicamente y cuando lo
hicieron solamente me arrojaron algún
objeto o me escupieron en la calle
enamorada y también como activista luche
por que el matrimonio igualitario fuera
una realidad en colombia y me casé
también escribió un libro ya les
contaron que se llama no somos etcétera
y hoy en día estoy resuelta a
convertirme en comediante
eso sí jamás he lanzado una piedra en
una manifestación
nunca he pintado una pared con un
graffiti y jamás he insultado a nadie en
un debate
cuando estás convencida de lo justo de
tu causa la defiendes respetando las
formas respetando el tono descubres que
las formas son importantes lo que tengo
claro a pesar de lo que se ve en esa
foto es que en estos temas el que se
desvele uca pierde cuando uno llega a
debates tiene que mantener la calma
la gente a veces se despista conmigo
porque cambio del lenguaje de pinta con
pintó el pelo lo dejo más largo
me pongo bala casi no me compro la carne
cal veo y efectivamente lo que me
interesa que quede claro es que yo
cambio de pinta pero no hay criterio
eso lo tengo igual
y es claro sin ninguna duda que a mí me
gusta sentirme distinta y construir me
distinta lo que de ninguna manera me
gusta es que me hagan sentir distinta
y muchas veces me han hecho sentir
distinta y además me han dicho que por
ser distinta mis derechos no son iguales
a los de los demás que tengo menos
derechos que el resto y es un hecho que
si soy distinta y además entiendo
perfectamente que representa un cambio
en una cultura que supone que todas las
personas somos heterosexuales pero
resulta que el cambio es esencial al ser
humano es una característica de nuestro
adn más profundo el cambio porque
nosotros los seres humanos aprendemos
modificamos los preconceptos y en
consecuencia cambiamos
el activismo viene a tratar de mujer de
mejorar el mundo viene a tratar de
buscar unas condiciones más adecuadas de
las que encontramos cuando llegamos a
este planeta o de las que nos tocaron
cuando empezamos a vivir la realidad que
vivimos
y en ese sentido encontramos que frente
a una situación que no es justa actuamos
funcionamos transformados y esa
transformación nos permite ayudar a
transformar el mundo
esta transformación nos permite dejar un
lugar distinto del que encontramos
cuando llegamos a este planeta lo que
busca entonces el activismo es un cambio
y ese cambio parte del hecho de asumir
que estamos en permanente movimiento que
estamos aprendiendo que estamos
cambiando y que en ese proceso es muy
enriquecedor reconocer que el otro
también está cambiando y eventualmente
puede no estar en la misma etapa en la
que nosotros estamos
pero eso no significa que no tratemos de
transformar el mundo y eso
fundamentalmente es involucrarse moverse
por algo
a todos ustedes a todos nos enseñaron a
discriminar a rechazar a poner al margen
al que es distinto
tenemos una pre concepción o un
prejuicio o una idea preconcebida acerca
de algo o de alguien y esa idea se
transforma a partir de una experiencia
humana con otra persona que pertenece a
ese grupo es lo que le pasa a la gente
que es homofóbica hasta que descubre que
su hijo es homosexual
hasta ahí les llega el homofobia porque
entienden lo que están haciendo y esa
experiencia con lo humano en el otro es
un cambio y es un cambio que desde el
activismo tratamos de mejorar
cómo fue que llegamos a esto
cómo fue que llegamos a aceptar
generalizadamente que tengamos una gente
al margen
cómo fue que terminamos creyendo que
efectivamente hay gente que está en el
otro lado por fuera que no tiene
derechos que funcione allá que no la
quiero ver y sobre todo porque toleramos
los discursos de gente que quiere
excluir a otra gente y peor todavía
votamos por ellos
qué fue lo que hizo que termináramos en
estas lógicas de solución del que es
distinto cuando esencialmente todas y
todos aquí somos distintos del resto
lo que nos hace iguales es que cada una
y cada uno de nosotros es diferente es
distinto y frente al hecho de que hay
alguien diferente yo puedo tomar varias
posiciones una es hago hasta lo
imposible por mantenerlo allá al margen
lo que sea necesario porque se mantenga
fuera esta es una posibilidad
la otra posibilidad es me siento
cómodamente a esperar a que la norma la
ley me diga que si le puedo hablar al
destruido o que si lo puedo reconocer
esa es otra posibilidad esperar el
cambio de la norma cómodamente sentados
a ver si de pronto si lo puedo reconocer
o no
pero hay otra opción y es reconocer al
otro en toda su diversidad en todas sus
posibilidades reconocer que el otro es
distinto y de esa manera yo aporto al
cambio y una cosa súper importante hago
que este además sea un momento histórico
mejor que este sea un país más chévere
que éste sea un planeta mucho más
incluyente y que la vida de esa persona
sea mucho más feliz para ser activista
hay que involucrarse hay que creer
profundamente que vale la pena trabajar
por algo o por alguien hay que tener la
convicción profunda de que vale la pena
y ojo con esto
valer la pena tiene dos acepciones una
es valió el sufrimiento el sacrificio o
el dolor esa es una definición de pena
la otra es valió el esfuerzo la energía
la pasión que le puse a ese ejercicio
lindo eso pueden imaginar eso vale la
pena y sobre todo valió la pena
he valido la pena de alguien más estoy
aquí porque alguien se esforzó en que
valiera la pena mi existencia y entonces
como un acto mínimo de reciprocidad lo
que debería hacer es involucrarme para
hacer mejor la vida de alguien más como
un acto de reciprocidad
y s
es el sentido ético que tiene el
activismo
entonces así es como el activismo
adquiere su dimensión no tiene sentido
si no está conectado con el otro no
tiene sentido si no reconoce al otro
sobre todo no tiene sentido si no
trabaja por el bienestar del otro
entonces yo no puedo decir que soy
activista en contra de los derechos de
los homosexuales
esos damas y caballeros se llama
homofóbicos por mucho que antes de
empezar cualquiera de esas afirmaciones
que hacen digan yo no yo homofóbico
yo no soy homofóbico pero a mí me parece
que los homosexuales y lo demás tampoco
puedo decir que soy activista racista
obvio que no y tampoco puedo decir que
soy activista en contra del derecho de
las mujeres a decidir sobre su propio
cuerpo porque eso se llama machismo o
anti derechos nada de eso es ser
activista podrá ser militante podrá ser
fanático o podrá ser mercenario
pero no es ser activista si la causa es
justa los medios para defenderla también
deben ser justos pero entonces
tendríamos que hablar del miedo porque
lo que hay detrás de la exclusión al
otro es miedo
es la incapacidad de descifrarlo
es la sorpresa de que este personaje ya
no sé qué voy a hacer con él no tengo ni
idea de cómo funciona entonces lo pongo
al margen
cuando yo pongo al otro al margen y lo
hago sentir diferente y lo excluyo y lo
pongo por allá donde no funcione yo
debería reconocer que lo que me está
motivando es el miedo yo tuve miedo
muchos años miedo a la discriminación y
miedo a la respuesta que tuviera cuando
dijera que soy lesbiana salir del closet
me libero sin duda pero sigo teniendo
claro que el miedo finalmente viene a
ser la expresión de que si hay una
posibilidad latente de que me
discriminen todo el tiempo es posible
puede ocurrir pero hay una cosa que me
mantiene con el corazón y la pila
recargada y es que estoy absolutamente
convencida de que es más la gente que
respeta e incluye que la gente que
discrimina
y eso además me da mucha esperanza y
tengo perfectamente claro además que
estas personas que incluyen y respetan
que invitan al primo a la fiesta de
matrimonio junto con todos los otros
primos y el primo viene con el novio y
los otros primos con sus parejas esas
personas que incluyen ya son activistas
ya están haciendo una diferencia y ya
están ayudando a transformar este mundo
a volverlo un lugar mejor
están reconociendo al otro lo están
valorando están partiendo del hecho de
que no importa qué tan distinto sea
sigue siendo muy valioso mi vida en el
mapa tengo que contar mi gran secreto
como activista y les voy a contar que mi
gran secreto como activista es que
cuando salí del clóset tuve dificultades
con mi papá y mi mamá pero cuando
lograron asimilarlo bien cuando ya
entendieron que su hija seguirá siendo
la misma de siempre y que por cierto en
este momento de la vida los necesitaba
más que nunca cada vez que pueden
cada vez que nos encontramos cuando los
llamó por teléfono me hacen saber que yo
he valido la pena y yo no tengo otra
respuesta que darles otra respuesta que
darle a la vida sino retribuir esa
maravilla con la que cuento y entonces
me involucro me activo y trato de hacer
la vida de otras personas mejor y trato
de que las posibilidades que encuentren
las personas sean distintas a las que yo
encontré cuando llegue a este planeta y
eso me hace sentir profundamente
orgullosa contada a esta parte emocional
pasó a contarles de lo que venía hablar
el activismo creativo fundamentalmente
es una apuesta en la que llevo algunos
años
y de qué se trata el activismo creativo
parte del reconocimiento del otro y de
la posibilidad de que el otro se
transforma
reconoce el cambio y el potencial que
ese cambio tiene para la sociedad para
la humanidad para avanzar no para
retroceder está conectado profundamente
con la humanidad del otro y esto
significa que busca su bienestar busca
su bienestar uno no hace activismo para
agregarle la vida a otra persona uno
hace activismo para mejorar las
condiciones de las personas que están en
unas condiciones inadecuadas
otra cosa que hace el activismo creativo
es apostarle a otros lenguajes y a otras
formas y en consecuencia no transige de
ninguna manera con la violencia ni
siquiera la verbal aporta en la causa
colectiva y busca consenso con otras
causas
entiende fundamentalmente que yo no soy
solo lesbiana o que una persona no es
solo una categoría identitaria que somos
mucho más que indígenas afros personas
con discapacidad o como homosexuales
podemos encontrar cosas en común mucho
más amplias aunque las reivindicaciones
en cada uno de esos lados sean
necesarias en lo particular pero hay que
encontrar el discurso colectivo buscar
otras causas y quiero mostrarles dos
ejemplos de activismo creativo
qué puede hacer una activista lesbiana
mamá si siente o se entera que la
iglesia de la cual hace parte la está
discriminando
esta es una opción es una posibilidad la
otra posibilidad es esta
en 2012 la conferencia episcopal en
medio de la crisis invernal más grande
que haya tenido el país en décadas
resolvió que el tema sobre el cual se
debía pronunciar el domingo de ramos en
todas las iglesias del país era los
homosexuales no son aptos para adoptar
y yo soy lesbiana y soy mamá y soy
católica y me sentí profundamente
insultado
que hicimos otras personas que eran
papas sus mamás y que además eran
católicas y que por supuesto también
eran homosexuales o bisexuales o trans
fuimos a misa con una camiseta en la que
por un lado se leía soy homosexual tengo
hijos soy católico y por el otro lado se
leía la homofobia no es cristiana
y que hicimos sólo ir a misa no hubo
consignas pancartas gritos declaraciones
de prensa nada solo estuvimos en misa
fue un acto de protesta super elocuente
y tan efectivo que al día siguiente la
conferencia episcopal recordó que había
una crisis invernal sin proporciones en
el país y que había un alto número de
damnificados por el invierno y cambio su
pronunciamiento la primera apuesta del
activismo creativo no parte de la forma
de cómo se va a manejar afuera
si no del adentro del yo no importa lo
que les diga a su pastor o sacerdote el
mandamiento del amor el primer
mandamiento no dice amarás al señor tu
dios sobre todas las cosas
el primer mandamiento lo que dice es
amarás al señor tu dios sobre todas las
cosas y al prójimo como a ti mismo y eso
lo que significa es que la medida del
amor es el amor propio
nadie da de lo que no tiene
y en ese sentido mi apuesta con el
activismo creativo también es invitar a
la gente a entender que somos distintos
y que además tenemos derecho a ser
distintos y que el hecho de ser
distintos no nos hace menos valiosos
les propongo entonces que esa sea la
primera etapa
el primer paso de un activismo creativo
aceptarse quererse dignificarse y
entender que no importa lo distinta que
yo sea soy valiosísima y tengo derecho a
existir y además
a existir a ser feliz y sobre todo a
construir me a partir de la felicidad y
esa apuesta de la felicidad individual
es central neurálgica en el activismo
creativo
por eso damas y caballeros les dejo con
esta invitación traten siempre de ser
felices y háganlo en venganza muchas
gracias